it's not five so Eddie you can't get
finesse classic edition anymore the
little mini one you can two big pieces
of news this week they discontinued the
NES classic globally and a big report a
big rumor about SNES smash Super
Nintendo whatever you want to call it
classic console coming out that would be
in the same vein the NES classic had 30
games on it so you might see that number
more or less we're not sure at this
point but obviously the SNES had an
incredible catalog of games Super
Metroid Super Mario Kart Zelda Link to
the Past so it'll be really interesting
to see what they do with that after the
NS classic you know sold out really
quickly they said they underestimated
demand this Christmas is when it's
rumored to come out so we have some time
to find out before I get started I think
we should finally put the rumor to rest
yes
Edmund and I are dressed exactly the
same but simply palette swap yeah
definitely like it was like the the
hardcore origins on the Black Watch and
your watch speaking of ever watch we're
here to talk about one of the world's
premiere team-based multiplayer shooters
Rainbow six age haha but what's
happening is when he was six Rainbow six
siege has been updated this week bunch
of operators got fixed or nerfed glass
was the main one that's been fixed in
this one
he recently he's the Russian sniper he
recently got it's like Widowmaker not
like Widowmaker at all or rich yes
that's that's the main difference
he recently got a thermal scope and
they've since changed it because it was
hard to tell like if your shots were a
hit or a Miss so they made a blood
splatter more prominent when you get a
successful hit and they've also reduced
the blur around your are highlighted
enemies the Japanese defender echo well
mike hunter not at all like Hanzo these
are Japanese defender he's Japanese
defender Hanzo has an opponent arrow
this guy has a robot drone controlled by
a yokai watch
hilarious use that joke class this week
his yokai drone can now target any part
of an enemy to disorient them when he
when he sets off his first effect thing
can you aim for the nads
I'm sure you could aim for the nads you
know what I might be better I might be
better try this weekend
I'll give that a shot I'm gonna let you
take this one because I can't pronounce
this guy's name
the shield operator Reinhardt no Monty
Monty Monty Monty new Monty what's going
Monty okay
the shield operator Monty has now had a
whose hipfire spread increased at medium
to long distances because there's a
little bit easy to get some pop shots
off where you had your big shield up so
that's been changed unfortunately though
Havana's gadget which is the wall
destroying pellet gun has not been fixed
there's a bug that randomly detonates
her pellets at random times
Ubisoft has investigated and they found
that the only way to fix it is to
rebuild the entire back end of our
gadget so that color working yeah so
it's a lot of work they're currently
working on that now and they're hoping
to push it out as part of the year -
season 2 that's currently running now in
realistic city it's so great that
Rainbow six is still getting the support
and still has a such a massive play base
exactly people like me love it in 2018
you're gonna get one vampire game but
it's made by the same people who made
the good eater series
vampires are definitely still in they
never left it sounds awesome it's anime
style we first got just like a cinematic
trailer and now we've got new images and
details
unfortunately no gameplay yet it looks
gorgeous it looks super stylish so
basically the story is your revenant
who's like a vampire basically you've
traded your memories for bloodlust and
like the ability to use these fancy
gifts we don't show what they are but
they're probably skills and stuff like
that coming 2018 home consoles likely
reference to ps4 Xbox one yeah probably
not PC which is kind of a shame but it
looks cool nonetheless the kids these
days Eddy they love Call of Duty they
love it it's the most popular thing in
the world
over 30 year old men left boiler duty
like mega cool GT World War two is gonna
be announced next week is that next week
yeah boy there's gonna be a live stream
event from Activision as they normally
do with these kind of big things you
know it's it's almost May so this is
their typical time frame for when
announced a new game coming from the
advanced warfare team at sledgehammer
games Michael Condrey the one of the
lead developers there at sledgehammer
talked about last year before she was
even talked about he said he wanted to
make a brand a band of brothers type
game so some could read into that maybe
it won't be exactly that but it's
interesting that's going back in time
they say back to roots it is probably a
good step for them at their infinite
warfare kind of you know stumbled in
terms of sales and reception generally
and if you want to catch that live
stream you can catch it on April 26 at
10:00 a.m. we want you to be there that
was like an Uncle Sam reference you know
like the posters for mobile to write
updated this week oh boy good for you
because you're still playing I don't
think it's possible to finish that game
it is because many people are finished
including me well I know this is the
exciting thing so they've made a couple
of changes to come with the update apart
from general bug fixes to big features
one you can listen to your own
background music please okay horizon has
good music well sometimes I want to just
jam to some you want Evanescence back
there ariana grande just like a little
anachronism in my in my future path what
about the Flintstones name zone maybe I
mean it's good to have the option yes
the other thing you can finally do is
drop those chests that you pick up that
contain items you can't put directly in
your inventory goddamn chests so say
your traps pouch is full
why the hell would you use traps okay
someone must use them so instead of just
carrying around chests that have traps
that you never need to replenish because
you never using traps or whatever other
item you can just drop them which is
really handy what else anything else
no it's just the to jump that's pretty
good okay well I mean well then there's
a lot of good news for this week
top 5 you could say top 5 years with
this week but if you want more good
stuff there is so much good [ __ ] on site
right now go mari cut your luck strip
you got a donut walk there you go boy
get a bunch of the Sena and Zelda
features you could just spend all day
reading our Zelda and persona features
watching as elder in persona creatures
anyway that's all for GS news top 5 this
week we'll be back next Tuesday with
Jessica cuz we've got a holiday on
Monday
bits until then stay safe
why why would they not be safe now I'm
worried
[Music]